what did scientists think about aging in
1931 that's right 1931 because this is
the year the first biological textbook
was published the science of life
written by H.D Wells sir Julian Huxley
and GP Wells the book itself is composed
of multiple books and last year I bought
the first book and I read it and having
enjoyed it so much and discovered that
it was part of this massive Ensemble
piece I managed to get my hands on the
first edition of this textbook this was
my face when I first received it as you
can see I was quite excited
as I so far I've only read the first
book called The Living body
and in this book the authors discussed
the body as a machine and that for the
present it is enough to remember that
all animals including men are combustion
engines of an intricate and curious
kinds which live by oxidizing their
Foods
now besides being surprised to find out
that H2 Wells wrote not just non-fiction
but biology non-fiction I was also
surprised to hear how both similar and
dissimilar their fuse were back in 1931
compared to today and I wasn't sure if
that was good or terrifying so how do
they think of human aging back in 1931
well in the last chapter of this first
book titled the wearing out of the
machine and its reproduction they
discuss it here are the chapters five
main takeaways we will go through and my
updated opinions on them
so firstly they already knew about
factors in the Bloods the authors
described that there seems to be an
accumulation of poisonous substances in
the blood it has been shown that if a
culture of healthy tissue from a growing
chick be mounted in blood serum from a
very old bird the cells cease forth with
to defied and grow
now I tried searching for this paper
one unfortunate aspect of this textbook
is that there are no references but I
can provide updated views today and they
are very much annoying it does seem that
either there is an accumulation of
pro-aging rathers in the blood or two a
decline in anti-aging factors or three
both
in the book they appear to be in support
of the first idea there's an
accumulation of pro-aging factors and
current data that supports this view
comes from research from the Convoy lab
which I presented before whereby they
diluted the blood plasma of old mice and
saw it rejuvenated the three tissue
layers but then just the other month I
presented some preliminary evidence that
perhaps a lot of youthful factors is
also taking place and injecting them
back in rats although this data hasn't
officially been published yet seems to
be quite promising and in a similar
thing this brings me on to the next
point where the author's then attributes
circulatory defects to most causes of
death
now obviously causes of death have
changed over time but regarding old age
they were somewhat spot on with the
trends that we see today
in most cases of natural death and
people over 50 the failure occurs in the
circulatory system the heart stops are
one of these different arteries bursts
and all the other tissues perish because
of the cessation of their blood supply
I like the way they phrase this
cooperativity here
it is important to realize that
ourselves do not die because mortality
is inherent in their vital structure
they die because they are part of a very
complicated system based on cooperation
and sooner or later one of the tissues
lets the other down
so like with point one back in 1931 they
really seem to emphasize the importance
of the circulatory system
there's the famous quote a man is as old
as his arteries from Thomas edinum I
will assume came from around 1670 as if
we know this to be true why does it seem
like I can say nothing smarter than what
I have already and that's we still have
the same Viewpoint that the circulatory
system is important
anyway another intelligent observation
they made was that they were aware that
aging affected tissues differently
there's an interesting review article a
recent one I should say that goes into
how the rate of Aging varies depending
on tissues and the authors here in his
book are in agreement different tissues
depend all away at different rates and
now there's even evidence from DNA
methylation a proxy for biological age
um one potential way of measuring
so-called biological age
that different tissues do indeed appear
to show you different rates of Aging
this could hint at what tissues or
organs would be most effective to Target
therapeutically
but interestingly the authors describe
in this book how the brain tissue goes
more rapidly than the cerebral arteries
so that the latter having their original
length but to shorten the course become
Twisted into curious loops and spirals
now I did a little digging into this
phenomenon and it turns out if you could
trace the brain fasculature at high
resolution you could use this as an
early indication of brain decline could
this be a predictive biomarker what
would be the most effective non-invasive
and cheap method to do this I don't know
I'm just thinking out loud but it's
curious
anyhow now for the big question what
were their thoughts on immortality in
1931 well they thought immortality had
potential
as a matter of fact living matter is
potentially immortal
they continue to say death as a
consequence of incomplete organization
the tissues die because they are parts
of an imperfectly balanced body
so how does one control balance you
could add or subtract something until it
all sort of weighs up which leads me to
the fifth points which is about hormones
now hormones in my opinion still seem
somewhat underexplored and guess what
they're also transported in the Bloods
the authors mentioned two men in this
book steinac and fornov who must have
been named back then but from my own
research were scientists slash fed slash
filters not really sure entirely they
were trying to rejuvenate the human body
in particular that took me down a
somewhat disturbing rabbit hole that
didn't involve rabbits but guinea pigs
monkeys and humans
and it was definitely interesting but a
little bit disturbing and I haven't
actually dug that deep yet but
essentially synap was performing Auto
plastic surgery that's involved sex
glands Faso ligation some rewiring of
the sex Clans essentially
while far enough was pioneering
heteroplastic surgery of sex gland
transplantation why the sex plans could
come from alternative sources
apparently there was some success albeit
only temporary and sometimes there was
no success at all
and frankly if I haven't really found
that it's true for this so if anyone has
please let me know although I don't know
if I do want to go that deep into this
rabbit hole anyhow they both had the
same view that Rejuvenation could be
triggered through additional hormones
coming from the sex plants so a little
bit speculative in my opinion
and the book doesn't go into any details
regarding this work it more references
the researchers suggesting that it was
assumed knowledge at the time
unfortunately I was not around in 1931
so I do not know
and then this idea of hormones has just
continued throughout the rest of the the
chapter
so to wrap up they had a pretty good
insight into the biology of humans even
back in 1931 and I think part of this is
due to the fact that they were quite
bold with their experiments rigorous
with their thoughts and details with
their descriptions in fact there are
many beautiful very detailed images in
this book
I'll make another video when I've read
the whole textbook because I'm sure it
will contain some nuggets of knowledge
it just may take me some time to read it
so for now enjoy some other non-fiction
books I've read
and help to read some books of your own
you might like to have some branded
bookmarks that I've designed otherwise
thank you to my patrons forces and thank
you for listening